hello and welcome to this video playing
FM Elias oh it's very high rated so um
okay let's play this line let's I Roman
seen it or something don't know this guy
yeah maybe start with this move getting
some kind of old Indian position I am
very high rated I think for for this
before this guy a played in before and I
don't remember him having such a high
rating mmm yeah really pretty 5 in this
position hmm ok I think I'll take this
opportunity to put a known f2 I'm a bit
surprised about p5 because it just it
looks like mostly weakening to me Queen
side is Maya my ground so to say so I'm
a bit surprised that he opens up there
before that's a 5 and this is really bad
for black so he has to take I guess
before a 5 is basically unplayable
so me esta Teague
maybe he not see for maybe that that
could be and something okay now that's
not player not objectively speaking
because the be four point is isolated
and very weak
okay so let's see night a4s normal move
just want to check if there's some
tactic that if it takes with the Queen
on a five-hour play Knight b6 winning
the Queen for two pieces okay so vago
night if I if I go in with the noid I
think I'll castle first you might be
able to sacrifice the exchange
and it's an interesting interesting
quest in teresting the question here 93
22 I can also just go Knight b6
not quite sure what's the most precise
movies yeah it was Sarah's kind of clay
wants to i'm giving a pawn here for dark
squared play which I don't want to do
really I don't want to take this pawn
okay I think I'm going in now
why we might let sacrifice the exchange
which is maybe not not enough
objectively but chanting blitz maybe
it's not so not as bad and like Knight
b6 I take on b6 and he just gives the
exchange this is so maybe something that
you can try or maybe Bishop g5 that's
also also move and I can take no I can
take them yeah okay so how to take I
think with the bishop and now I expect
him to give the exchange I don't think
yeah don't think you can and fought
without it cannot play without it okay
so I'm putting this falls through 46
which you will probably prevent no
Bishop d7 that's not a move he has to go
there okay so i think i have to put the
Queen on the cria King on the side so
what I said in the opening like okay
this is not playable it led to the
window of an exchange which is not the
size of yet but it is it is a good
position um yeah what we had to put it I
think here yeah so this is invading
it's not easy to get rid of that get rid
of that piece okay maybe this maybe this
okay that's kind of interesting still
may be here all right I'm not quite
positive how I get the get this
activated here and I mean this is this
is not looking good with the night but I
wonder want to see if I'll him
hmm I really got compensation here for
the exchange quite clearly it's
especially it's especially tricky to
play it's much easier for him to play
this position
check check okay so at least oh I didn't
think about that move at all okay i
still have hook age 8 and things like
that so I'm not getting my rook trapped
whoo difficult so let's go there can I
somehow get me is king here with my
queen probably not probably not now some
nights e4 and f4 maybe it's the a4 can
be a problem but ok you wants to go a
form I want and I try to now this is a
time or actually a threat now on h6
g5 rook h8 maybe h 8 a-4 h6 threatening
then Quincy five is a big threat it's
got f6 though maybe have six saving
saving his day here oh wow check that's
its winning right now that's made less
resumes and it was tough I realized too
i'm still pretty and pretty clear that
this is not a playable position / black
after a five this is pretty pretty
terrible but i think i played and played
played it badly rugby ain't castles and
here i should play g3 here probably that
night a form of helped him helped him a
great deal maybe g3 the problem with
this position is I mean he's almost now
forced to give the exchange at some
point when I get into b6 because if it
doesn't and tolerates a piece staying on
b6 then I would just win before for no
compensation whatsoever like with queen
bee three queen before so it's this is
just a question of the circumstances of
him losing the exchange this is also why
has said that that is bad four
blagghhhhh yeah this kind of thing
because this is a certain scenario that
will happen and he does not have enough
for the exchange of a playwright but the
way it went he had some very decent play
for the exchange chance this and now
giving this up this is a this is not
easy at all because he's got two bishops
and this bishop here this is always a
big annoyance I think that really helped
him it's interestingly enough that night
air because maybe because of the
activity here so maybe I should go here
if he goes be sure
five maybe this move and now if he if he
gives the exchange now and it's actually
f4 well now this is this is still I'm
still not easy at all I mean it is
objectively much better white but it's
not easy yeah the computer is on a
stable plus 1 which is how I see it as
well but Chang it's not easy and here
the position gets gets very very okay
for like I think I'm pretty sure he's
totally fine IAM 91 is debatable of
course the way I play the chair not
putting the night on d3 but I wasn't
quite sure where this is going there
from d3 so here yeah the computer and
just gives this as equal as pollution
now it gives me some edge with h3 okay
okay oh I didn't see that Bishop 27 well
I mean I saw that this is a move but I
didn't really think it is much good but
I think he gets he gets a foreign right
this is the thing oh no it is that wow
that sets very very bad I cannot cover
everyone haha who so I have made a
blunder here I made a blunder here
Quincy to I have to go look G ATM Jenna
the engine says equal but I'm a little
bit skeptical hear about the engine on a
unit on a not so yeah without having
calculated really deeply because the
black be porn might be very dangerous I
think what the engine is card is seeing
is
kind of perpetual with a 4 root g7 Queen
286 that's a wacky line takes know maybe
you should be aid I don't understand the
computer line it on and gives I Queen
here for the check okay that I do
understand hmm yeah very murky I will
have my doubts either the black black
possibilities here with a 4 are quite
dangerous I mean the computer likes my
position but I said I'm a little bit
skeptical here gee 8 26 and now no I'm
actually winning with Queen Queen d2 so
this is winning age four wins here i'm
not so sure actually a 4 here no f6 then
I wasn't sure about if this is this is
very yeah very tough business h4 was was
my idea and the computer says equal okay
the chalice King g8 queen age 6 all
right now let's know it gives widen
advantage okay that's very very
difficult to say in the practical game
there with a couple of seconds on the
clock anything can happen it's clear
that this just wasn't best because
that's made in three or something like
that yeah so that was a bit lucky at the
end I really had a excellent position
out of the opening but it wasn't a
totally clear fair the way it went down
I won the exchange but he had plenty of
compensation for it okay thanks for
watching